Traduttore: Marco Caresia
Revisore: Andrea Giglio
Buon pomeriggio.
Si, quattrocentomila, ottocentomila
non stava dando i numeri.
Effettivamente è proprio così.
Per fortuna che non li vediamo,
tra l'altro, questi virus,
perché non potremmo neanche muoverci.
Possiamo respirare ovviamente.
Vedete, prima di tutto,
come già stato detto,
questi virus non sono tutti lì
ad aspettarci, saltarci addosso.
E poi noi veniamo
da milioni di anni di evoluzione
fianco a fianco con questi virus,
quindi abbiamo tutte le difese
che ci consentono di vivere
in armonia con questi microrganismi.
Però qualche volta le cose
non sono sempre così perfette.
Qualcuno di questi virus, ogni tanto,
trova il modo di bucare queste difese
e le conseguenze che vediamo
possono essere catastrofiche.
Fortunatamente questo
non succede molto spesso,
è una cosa che succede raramente,
però succede.
L'abbiamo visto più o meno regolarmente
anche nel secolo scorso,
ogni tanto lo vediamo anche ora.
Prendiamo per esempio il virus HIV,
un virus che dal 1981 ad oggi
ha fatto 35 mila vittime.
40.000 persone vivono oggi
con questo virus.
Diciamo la verità,
che ce ne siamo un po' dimenticati, eh?
Infatti gli ultimi dati suggeriscono
che il numero di casi è in aumento,
soprattutto in Europa.
Perché ce ne siamo dimenticati?
Be’, perché la ricerca
ha fatto un buon lavoro
e ci ha prodotto dei farmaci
che permettono di bloccare
la replicazione di questi virus.
Peró non è ancora abbastanza.
Questi farmaci non curano,
non tolgono il virus,
non eradicano l'infezione.
E poi pensate, dal 20% al 30%
delle persone sieropositive
non sanno di esserlo.
Per cui ce la terremo ancora un po’
questa epidemia tra i piedi.
Allora cosa dobbiamo fare?
Innanzitutto dobbiamo esserne consapevoli,
la prevenzione è sicuramente
la prima cosa.
E poi dobbiamo studiare,
dobbiamo conoscere.
Dobbiamo cercare di capire come funziona
questo virus e tutti gli altri virus,
perché non vogliamo
che queste cose continuino a ripetersi.
Allora la ricerca sui virus
è sicuramente importante
e quella che vi racconto adesso
è la mia storia personale
con questo virus.
Però voglio che voi la prendiate
come un po’ un testimonial,
perché non è una storia eccezionale
io stesso non mi definisco assolutamente
un ricercatore eccezionale
però è la storia che decine, centinaia,
migliaia di colleghi miei,
alcuni sono anche in questo teatro,
hanno vissuto e vivono.
Quindi ripercorriamo insieme
questa storia: io, dopo la laurea,
mi sono appassionato dei virus.
Sì, ci si può anche appassionare di virus,
succede, succede!
Decido quindi di andare a fare
un dottorato di ricerca a Londra.
I virus mi appassiono sempre di più
e allora cosa faccio?
Vado in un laboratorio importante
dove si studia HIV.
In quel momento un mistero di questo virus
era una piccola proteina.
Questa proteina si chiama NEF.
È una proteina di cui il virus ha bisogno
per andare ad infettare altre cellule.
Senza questa proteina c'è qualcosa
che non va nel virus,
ma non si sa che cosa.
Questa era la domanda a cui io volevo
trovare assolutamente una risposta.
Bene, due anni in questo laboratorio,
ad Harvard, ci convincono
che quello che succede è
che le cellule hanno un'arma contro HIV.
Quest'arma funziona,
peró funziona solo quando l'HIV
non ha questa sua proteina, NEF.
Sembra che il virus usi questa proteina
per difendersi da questa arma,
però bisogna trovarla quest'arma,
bisogna capirla.
Bene, è in questo momento
che ricevo una telefonata
che mi mette un po' in crisi.
Una telefonata che arriva dall'Italia,
che mi dice:
“Dai, torna a lavorare in Italia,
torna all'Università.”
Sapete che era come una specie
di sogno primordiale che avevo,
quello di tornare vicino
alla mia famiglia, al mio Paese…
Non riesco a resistere: ritorno.
Però ogni volta
che faccio questi spostamenti
diventano sempre più complicati.
Con me ora torna mia moglie,
che ho trascinato dalla Svezia,
e la imbarco in questa avventura.
Due anni son passati
e mi accorgo che questo non è per me,
il mio sogno non era quello primordiale,
quello era una cosa che tenevo dentro,
ma non mi accorgevo qual era
veramente la cosa che volevo fare.
Era tornare a fare la mia ricerca,
quindi butto tutto alle ortiche:
un posto fisso e trascino tutti ancora
dall'altra parte dell'Oceano
e poi, dove trovo le opportunità
per portare avanti questo lavoro?
E quindi ecco, questa volta si va
a Londra, Imperial College.
Qui mi capita di fare
una scoperta molto strana.
Allora: voi sapete
che i virus sono queste cose
che stanno tra il vivente e il non vivente
e hanno bisogno di una cellula
per realizzarsi, per replicarsi.
E bene, allora le cellule
che uso in questo laboratorio,
mi dicono che il virus
non ha più bisogno di NEF.
Ma come?
Quello che studiavo, che ho studiato
per quattro, cinque anni,
non c'è più, è sparito.
Un bel problema, eh?
Qualcuno decreta la morte
di questo progetto
e della mia carriera di ricercatore.
Ma io insisto, cerco di capire
che cosa è questa cosa.
Bene, quattro anni di ricerca mi dicono
che dentro queste cellule c'è
un virus nascosto
che nessuno aveva notato.
Pensate: un virus
che infetta i topi, non l'uomo.
Era lì, invisibile…
Come ci è finito?
È stata una contaminazione avvenuta
anni fa da parte di altri ricercatori.
Contaminazione.
Allora, guardate,
io lavoravo nell'edificio
che sta alla vostra destra
in questa immagine.
Cent'anni prima, nell'edificio
alla vostra sinistra,
ci lavorava un signore,
si chiamava Alexander Fleming.
Ah, lo conoscete!
Allora conoscete anche la storia.
Stava per partire per una vacanza estiva,
questo signore lavorava con i batteri,
e si è dimenticato sul bancone
del laboratorio questa coltura batterica.
È tornato dopo le vacanze
e non era molto sorprendente
che questa piastra di batteri
fosse ammuffita.
Però lui l'ha guardata e ha detto:
“Ah, però, la muffa uccide i batteri!”
Bene, questa è stata la scintilla,
come sapete, che ha poi portato
alla scoperta della penicillina.
Quindi che cosa:
questa storia è un’ispirazione per me.
Allora che cosa mi dicono
le cellule contaminate con questo virus?
Mi dicono che probabilmente questo virus
che non interessa assolutamente a nessuno,
non voglio offendere i topi, però…
Vuol dire che questo virus
ha sviluppato una sua proteina
che fa quello che fa NEF per HIV.
Vuol dire allora
che quello che sto cercando
è una cosa fondamentale.
Una cosa che non interessa
solo “un” virus,
ma “i” virus, probabilmente.
Questo mi rende veramente determinato,
devo assolutamente trovarlo.
Certo bisogna convincere
qualcuno a darmi soldi, però,
per studiare un virus
che fa del male ai topi
e non all'uomo… insomma…
E allora ecco
che decidiamo di trasferirci,
però ogni volta, ripeto,
questo diventa sempre più complesso.
Ora c’è mia figlia, Sofia,
che ha 3 anni, all'epoca,
e già parla tre lingue correttamente,
e la obblighiamo a trasferirci
in un'altra nazione
dove deve imparare la quarta lingua.
Però, vedete, la ricerca si fa
con le risorse, si fa con la visione,
e io devo trovare quell'ambiente
che me lo fa fare.
E allora decidiamo di tornare in Italia:
“Ma come, in Italia?
Ma non lo sai che in Italia
non si può fare ricerca?
Lo sanno tutti.”
Questo era un ritornello
che continuavano a dirmi:
"Ma non t'è bastata la prima volta?
Sei dovuto scappare!"
Be’, è successo che ho conosciuto
questo centro di ricerca proprio a Trento
e ho scoperto che c'erano
tutti gli ingredienti
che mi interessavano.
C'erano le risorse e, soprattutto,
vedete, c'era la visione di sostenere
la ricerca per quello che è,
la volontà di conoscere,
la volontà di sapere
e di conoscere alla radice le cose,
perché, anche se a priori
non possiamo sapere l'utilità
che i nostri studi possono darci,
siamo convinti che proprio questa ricerca
ci porti alla scoperta.
D'altronde che scoperta è una scoperta
che facciamo solo
perché l'avevamo prevista?
Allora succede quello che non ti aspetti.
Dopo tutti questi anni, in meno di un anno
scopriamo una cosa:
che le cellule hanno una proteina,
questa proteina che si chiama SERIN 5,
tanto più è presente nelle cellule,
tanto più il virus ha bisogno
di questa sua difesa che si chiama NEF.
Era proprio quello che volevamo trovare.
Questa proteina funziona con una specie
di mantello che ricopre tutta la cellula.
Succede che il virus,
quando esce dalla cellula,
si porta dietro questo mantello.
Però vedete:
in questo mantello il virus funziona
un po' come una camicia di forza
che lo intrappola e gli impedisce
di entrare poi in una nuova cellula.
Allora perché siamo qui
a parlare di un virus
che ha ucciso 35 milioni
di persone finora?
Eh, perché i virus, purtroppo,
hanno fatto un passo più di noi,
almeno alcuni virus.
E allora ecco che il virus,
con la sua proteina NEF,
obbliga la cellula a trasportare
questo mantello all'interno
cosicché quando il virus
esce dalla cellula non ha più
questa copertura, questo rivestimento.
E allora cosa possiamo fare ora
che abbiamo scoperto questa cosa?
Intanto, questa è una difesa
che sembra molto antica,
perché tutti gli organismi animali
ce l'hanno.
E adesso possiamo cercare di capire
come sviluppare un farmaco
per inibire questa proteina NEF del virus,
cosicché la difesa possa avere la funzione
che dovrebbe avere.
L'altra cosa che stiamo facendo,
è quella di capire proprio dal modo
in cui SERIN 5, questa proteina, funziona,
di capire come sviluppare un farmaco
che ne mimi l'azione
senza però essere riconosciuto
dalla proteina NEF.
La cosa bella è che negli ultimi sei mesi,
da quando abbiamo riportato
questa ricerca,
ci sono almeno 20 laboratori
in tutto il mondo
che stanno facendo questa cosa.
Tutti insieme quindi si spera di arrivare
a fare questo passo successivo
per combattere queste malattie.
Ora, vedete, quando mi è stato chiesto
di partecipare a quest'evento,
non ero sicuro, perché dicevo:
“Ma che cos'ha a che fare
il coraggio di osare con questa scoperta?”
Una cosa che non riuscivo a connettere.
Quindi quello che ho fatto
è stato di ripercorrere
proprio come ho fatto adesso insieme a voi
e, a mente fredda ho visto che, be’,
di coraggio di osare
ce n'è stato, probabilmente.
C'è stato, da parte mia,
nel continuare a seguire
questa passione, questo sogno,
nonostante le difficoltà,
nonostante tutti questi spostamenti.
Le persone che mi circondano
e mi circondavano,
la mia famiglia che ha creduto
in questa cosa e mi ha sostenuto.
E poi, molto importante, la volontà
di chi ha la capacità
di sostenere la ricerca
e di capire che la ricerca
deve essere fatta a 360°.
E allora se vi devo lasciare
con una… Scusate…
Il punto è che, riguardando indietro,
ho capito che non avevo capito
che effettivamente serviva coraggio…
Non me n'ero accorto.
Ero talmente distratto e concentrato
nel seguire la mia cosa, la mia passione,
che proprio non me n'ero accorto.
E allora questo è il messaggio
che vi voglio dare:
lo so che bisogna essere…
bisogna avere anche la fortuna
per poter seguire la passione,
però cercate di farlo senza esitazione
perché, se seguite la passione,
troverete sicuramente il coraggio di osare
e non avrete neanche bisogno di cercarlo.
Grazie.
(Applausi)